wife in Pakistan is getting too
expensive for baha'u'llah he says the
government is to blame
he is among thousands of people
traveling from the southern city of
Karachi to Islamabad to call on
Pakistan's prime minister Imran Khan to
resign our nagamma said the air
inflation has increased so much we are
helpless we can't pay for our children's
school fees or save money to buy a home
we feel powerless
faced with a weak economy and high
inflation rate protesters say a decent
living wage is becoming a luxury before
taking office in 2018 Imran Khan said
his economic plan would generate
millions of jobs but budget deficits and
limited foreign reserves have crippled
growth supporters say he deserves credit
for reaching a six billion dollar
bailout agreement in May with the
International Monetary Fund but the
austerity measures had followed haven't
been well-received this useless
government has been in office for one
year and nothing has been done for
people they are involved in corruption
and the inflation was not as high with
previous governments we will stay here
until the government resigns the
anti-government protests have also
turned into a sign of solidarity for
Muslims living in indian-administered
Kashmir the disputed territory which was
stripped of its autonomy in August while
religious groups and political rivals in
the so called Jui
or Jamaat ulama al-islam party organized
the protests virtually all parties have
used a march to show their grievances
protesters like the Haruna say their
patience is wearing thin tired of empty
promises they say they're ready for the
long road ahead
Katya Lopez with a yawn al-jazeera